it is
all right you guys have all fired a nerf
blaster that's why you're probably here
to watch this video of course now did
you know there's a new kid on the block
that's right x shot is here and they
wanted to say we have blasters too
they're pretty sweet they're pretty
reliable and come at a way better price
you should compare them against their
nerf equivalents now you might think
that us taking a video that's sponsored
by xchat means that we're gonna be
biased well not true they said we want
to look our competitor in the eye and we
want to see which ones you would trust
in battle with your friends instead of
going through every single nerf blaster
ever made we've picked our six favorite
x-shot blasters and we're gonna compare
them directly to their nerf counterparts
first challenge is a distance challenge
basically we're going to be placing ren
here at the end of the hall what and
wren is going to be our target we're
going to see if we can know what's going
on all right i know exactly we're doing
a distance test we're going to shoot
okay since we're comparing these guys we
broke out some of the most expensive
tape we own it's green felt tape
wow
all right guys you're each gonna fire
three times at the same time out of the
three who goes further i'm gonna start
with the raider it's a side mounted
magazine classic nerf pump action
we're gonna go up against the
regenerator
three two one
three shot two
[Music]
the nerf darts slide on the ground
better next we have the roto fury which
shoots mega darts and is got 10 darts
rotating i think this is going up
against the turbo advance which has 40
darts and it's under 30 bucks
make sure you both even get the same
light all right
three two
oh it one
you yeah the [ __ ] won that one
that one tied up one more
shot by a hair next we're gonna take the
rough cut which is a shotgun style nerf
blaster and we're going to compare that
to the vigilante
break action shotgun style over under
love it shotties
go
[Music]
all right
go
play x shot wow oh that was a clear
winner by nerf next we are going to take
the retaliator elite that's going up
against the max attack bottom fed meg
loaded rifle style x shotgun three two
one
next shot big shot after that the
maverick rev6 is a classic revolver
style nerf blaster it's coming up
against the bug
shots going up against the swarm
that's going up against the swarm seeker
similar style but magazine's bad three
two one
egg shot
egg shot wow whoa this guy's
so here's my theory as to why x shots
going further we have tested these guns
off camera too with the same darts uh
we're using slightly different designs
using x-shot darts and neck shotguns
nerf darts and nerf guns the x-shotguns
do shoot a little bit harder but the
shorter darts they get blast out of the
gun a little bit quicker because they
weigh a little bit less so i think the
dart design has something to do with the
distance and of course the gun design as
well last but not least
the little guys the most powerful the
most dangerous the most deadly this is
the nerf reflex that's going up against
the x-shot micro which is in my opinion
my favorite dark gun ever made three two
one
oh hit carmichael carmichael what's the
foot range you're standing at
61.
all right i think it's clear
by and large
these x shots shoot further than their
nerf counterparts
this one especially it's super accurate
i didn't hit the wall
i want to go for the world record
you guys already see the movie wanted
80 feet
[Music]
whoa wow
whoa 78.
wow
that was pretty damn accurate so we're
going to do one shot of each gun here
for the accuracy test the reason for
that is because when you're counting on
that one shot to make your day and win
the game that's when the accuracy
matters all right
yeah
three
two one
ain't you in the face
you hit me but i missed you all right
three luke skywalker two
one
ready
go did i hit you you hit me right here
you hit me right here oh i guess these
guns are equally accurate do you think
the operator uh accuracy has anything to
do with this
son
i have a really good shot son i'm a
little lower son oh dude you're good
it's gonna drop don't worry
ready yeah come on
you hit me right here my belt
no it's nerf baby i knew i didn't want
to
honestly though i expected with the
heavier dart that they'd be more
accurate
so far
yeah we're about to find out
hey man
this is a unique experience if you're
watching
but um
this is what how nick and i normally
talk to each other
yeah
accurate oh nico's back
hey
let's do this
three
two one
oh
who are you
dude it's like equivalent it's time it's
time hi
how are your cats my cats just got fixed
oh nice dude
they're loving the it life man it feels
like it's been a week since we talked
yeah
okay
three
two
one
that's dead center dude yeah
yeah
but i was closer to the center of the
center of mass all right
i'll give you that one all right this is
the future of parenting honestly like
talk to your friends this way in the
future
we're starting that right now i mean
having a family you know i don't know
no yeah me neither actually
so why is your hair great because i'm an
x-man final round for accuracy the
raider versus the regenerator
three
two
one
damn i gotcha that was a direct hit
so for accuracy x shot takes four of the
categories nerf takes two
there's only one more
what's that the reload duel
we are going to do this royal rumble
style so the last man standing will be
the ultimate winner each person of each
round who wins will advance to the next
round hands on your head
all the way up sam no cheating three
two
one
[Applause]
oh wait am i facing off against
yes you are
good luck
oh and also wait okay wait that mag is
that drum doesn't actually come out of
the gun it does not
so let's leave this in the gun
this is they're all the same you start
with dart out
how is this the same as that it is
we're testing them across the same the
same pattern of putting the magazine
together across different blasters so
there is no magazine putting together on
this one well that's okay i think we
just need to be more positive
visually yeah just put it on the
universe that you can do this and you'll
be able to
you could do it dude
i can do this
ready guys say your prayers
three two
rigged
i'm volunteering myself for this
challenge
and
three two one go
it's so not fair
that one wasn't fair man this one is
like
please please someone defeat me so i can
get back to work i'll defeat you
three two one
hat's a little big but hey i'll still
wear it
give me one item of clothing
i'm getting that hat dude
if you miss
go get another dart ready
three two one go
me let me let me put this level five
shirt on
i'm ready to do that i'm gonna make one
valiant effort for x shot here and hope
that it turns out in my favor yeah i'm
ready
in three two
one
[Music]
take that shirt oh
gabe i'm sorry about your shoes at least
i can get back to work
[Applause]
well that's it i hope you guys learned
something about the durability the
distance the accuracy of all of these
blasters i mean the reload challenge
that might have just been clint you know
really good but who knows when it comes
to dark blasters we've actually been
super impressed with x-shots qualities
they shoot really hard they're very
accurate and honestly they're super
affordable if you're looking for a
competitor to nerf you're looking to try
something else check out x-shot they
have some really cool designs turbo
advance there's nothing like that that
nerf makes and this the micro it's 2.99
and this is legitimately one of my
favorite dart guns now shoot the lens
oh oh that's like three bucks some
quality like dlc right here
it's a quality micro transaction quality
micro transaction right here there's
only one thing left to do oh yeah you
need to go watch our film fortnite video
which came out of the corridor channel
right now
that and and subscribe subscribe and
remember all the links to all the x shot
blasters you saw in this video are in
the description
so if you want to go and pick one up
definitely go over there and check it
out i think the only thing left to do is
to go play a battle with these
okay all right let's do it let's do it